major money milestones look so look
when it comes to the money game right
sometimes you just got to take a look at
yourself
and look at the man in the mirror or the
woman in the mirror vanessa's case or
our friends out there take a look in the
mirror like michael jackson i'm talking
to the man in the mirror sometimes you
got to assess yourself and sometimes you
know you know i need to do you need to
make that change
right so
when it comes to these major money
milestones here's what i want you to do
i want you to find out where you're at
depending on your age
are you reaching these five important
financial milestones this is an article
from go banking rate so let's get into
these major money milestones
so if you want to if you care about
reaching financial independence this is
uh something that i've said we're
obviously very concerned about that's
why we're here talking money
here are a few of the big ones that you
need to accomplish number one are you
ready
number one
you think i'm gonna start with save that
money obviously that's like that's like
before you've even like you've saved
that money already then you're gonna you
know we we're graduating gotcha number
one
have an active
brokerage account in your 20s do you
have an after active brokerage account
yet no i'm actively broke though
okay
so if you're young today david young
david vanessa up there congratulations
right your knees work yeah you you can
go out drinking you're not hungover for
three days walk funny but the but the
best thing that you got on your side
the greatest
thing that every young investor every
young person has on their side is
time t-i-m-e time time is your greatest
weapon so you don't need a lot of money
or investing experience when you get
time on your side you get the greatest
tool of all time right so all you got to
do is start kicking in some of your
spare change investing you're maxing out
certain brokerage accounts your
retirement accounts um
and then you let compounding do the rest
vanessa i would love to actually see you
maybe
we forgot about that but anyway so
that's number one have an active
brokerage account in your 20s this can
be i look at this two ways
number one this might just be a
retirement account we talk about all the
time a 401k
or a roth ira or an ira these are
retirement accounts cool or just a
brokerage account maybe that's what the
robo advisor or a low cost trading
platform where you can invest or trade
stocks bonds mutual funds etfs important
things david i know that you're learning
and as we said by a hundred episodes in
you're gonna be a billionaire so in
order to get to that
point in your life
we got to get you a brokerage account
you ready to do this let's do it man we
got a 401k here at valuetainment have
you not signed up for that uh
we're gonna do that after the show buddy
all right so anyone out there um
that's number one start with an active
brokerage account in your 20s number two
be one of those well-qualified buyers
you keep hearing about in your 30s what
does that mean well-qualified buyers
are the people with excellent credit
which means their credit scores are
north of 700
and approaching 800 did you know
david what do you think the highest
possible credit score is
and if you guys know it in the answer in
the comment section
highest possible credit score do you
know the number
it's gotta be like what 900 something
okay that's your guess 900 vanessa
highest possible credit score
one thousand one thousand people in the
comment section what do we got it's got
to be something king auto 800
all right the number is 850. die
50. you weren't bad
you were at uh i was ambitious you
weren't bad all right so 8.50
the fico credit scoring system that's
what people use it goes all the way up
to 850. so those with 800 or more
they're able to get the lowest rates
they're able to get the best deals and
they take out loans and their finance
purchases now me i'm not a person that
basically one of the things i always say
is you know what's more important than a
high credit score what's that a high net
worth bingo when you got a lot of money
and your net worth is uh
is chilling as i'd like to say you don't
necessarily need to put a lot of things
on credit or rely on your credit score
but it is important to have a high
credit score versus a low credit score
so if you're in the 7
750 800 range you're doing great if
you're anywhere near 850 you're crushing
the game so here's an analogy you know
what i would equate the
credit score to what's that a good gpa
okay
but a good gpa or a good credit score
doesn't necessarily mean you're going to
be successful guaranteed in life as an
example pat always talks about having a
1.8 gpa the guy's doing okay
he's got one point eight com zero zero
zero comma comma comma comma after that
the guy's doing all right so it's
important the credit score the gpa is an
analogy right there so just like in
school you kind of want to have a good
credit score um so you can go on the
class trip right so make sure you got a
good gpa number three
this is something we talked about in one
of the first house cast how much money
you should have by a certain age
in your 40s you should have three times
your salary saved up for retirement okay
so number one we talked about having an
active brokerage account in your 20s
number two be one of those
well-qualified buyers you keep hearing
about in your 30s high credit score
number three have three times your
salary saved up for retirement in your
40s so get to put it in perspective
by age 30
you should have your annual salary saved
for retirement so what does that mean
you make 50 gs a year by age 30 you
should have 50 grand in your retirement
account okay not bad but by age 40
you should have three times your annual
salary
okay in a retirement account so if you
make 50 grand a year use that analogy
that's 150 grand and a 401k or roth ira
or in a retirement account awesome
that's six times your annual salary by
age 50 that's followed by eight times
your annual salary by age 60 and 10
times by retirement age which is
typically 67 so i know that 10 times
sounds a little bit crazy
but the younger you start
the easier it'll be you can get there
okay
number four on this list right there's
five tips that we're going through
number four have your end of life
affairs in order
by your 50s
this to me is a little controversial
it's like 50s you need to be but yeah
things happen
50s
you you know a generation ago when life
expectancy was 65 67 in this country by
50 you already you know you're already
in the third quarter of life
by 50 now
if you're taking care of yourself you're
maybe at the midway point right like you
know people are healthy so
but like bicky's album ready to die you
never know okay
so they recommend basically getting your
affairs in order with things like trusts
living trusts power of attorney making
sure that you got insurance in place
right inheritance what's going to happen
wills and trusts that we always talk
about long-term care so if we have
people in their 50s that are watching
the show these are things that you maybe
need to be focusing on uh this is the
difference between leaving a lasting
legacy or leaving behind a basically a
cluttered mess
to your beneficiaries and your uh loved
ones so it can get ugly out there um
it ain't pretty some of this stuff to
talk about we talked about your
end-of-life affairs by age 50.
but i don't know anybody that's ever
lived forever so eventually that time uh
is gonna come so it ain't it ain't fun
it ain't pretty talk about but it needs
to get done that's number four number
five to wrap this one up you gotta have
a supplementary income stream by you
know what by by what age oh god what by
what age 26 what he said
something so
no matter your age whether you're in
your 20s your 30s your 40s it was a
trick question i think we got me i
gotcha i think we learned during the
pandemic
you never know what's gonna happen do
you have a side hustle you can monetize
right side hustle was never a thing a
generation ago nobody had side hustles
you had a job that you maybe worked at
for 40 years and you know you collected
a pension your gold watch that's it
you're out the door
now
everybody's got a side hustle to put
things in perspective i've worked in
uh financial services in the life
settlement world for almost 15 years
that's my income stream that's how i met
pat an insurance conference you know 10
years ago
this little show sas talks money once
started as a little side hustle me
telling a buddy of mine hey i really
think that millennials kind of don't
understand how money work and i kind of
want to help some people out and i'm
very fortunate
that i've
become this successful person in my
field and i want to help people and it
started off as an idea that turned into
a side hustle that turned into my own
show here on valuetainment so a side
hustle starts on the side and eventually
maybe takes the place
of your real career anyway that's a
little side hustle um
clearly
with the pandemic and everything that's
happened with that
i think people are recognizing the
importance of a side hustle
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauz cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken